today I will be talking with you about
what's that one Wikipedia I work for the
Wikimedia Foundation as a product
manager and I was a software engine
before there's that and I've written a
lot of parts for Wikipedia and that's
why I'm credible enough to write about
this and talked with you about this also
I will be taking questions offline after
the talk so I'll just come up to me if
you have any questions alright so as we
all know all good talks start with a
quote right I spent a bunch of time
looking for a quote about a bot you know
Einstein must have written something but
I really couldn't find anything so I
wondered if I was approaching this the
wrong way turns out the internet is full
of bots that love to write quote
inspired by it is one of those designed
to generate hilarious ridiculous quotes
so before we go any further let's settle
on the definition of a bot wait I know
let's ask Wikipedia Oh
so for the sake of simplicity let I'll
go with the simplest definition of a bot
for now a bot is a program or a
collection of programs written in a
programming language that do automated
tasks on the Internet a bot can do tasks
at a much higher rate at than a human
users which is why they're used for
repetative tasks also we are strictly
talking about computer BOTS and
excluding edge cases like sucker bot
I'm sure you've all so I'm sure you've
all come across spots on the Internet
right they are so oh because on the one
we have according to research last year
about 52% of all web traffic is by BOTS
and that is a shocking number that
should give us all pause having so many
BOTS on the interwebs can have
far-reaching consequences as we have all
probably seen however not all bots are
bad BOTS can be extremely helpful in a
variety of ways let's take a look at
some of the more popular boss on social
media here's an example of a reddit bot
that corrects grammatical errors made by
other
and it comes up with unusual tips to
remember these the right spelling here's
an example of the butt correcting
someone who's correcting someone else
here's another reddit bot that suggests
an xkcd based on a user's comment it's
actually really accurate there's another
one that follows the first one around
and transcribes the xkcd link posted by
the first part here's a pretty cool
Twitter bot that combines two different
news headlines to come up with a single
coherent news headline that my go-to
source for all news these days and
here's one that likes to give people
tips on how to live a meaningful and
happy life ironically so what can be
silly and funny but they can also be
very useful like this messenger pod that
gives you health tip suggests diets and
fitness videos or this slag pod that
suggests meeting times for people based
on their calendar schedules but can also
teach you new languages recommend books
and movies personalized to your tastes
what can come up with intelligent feed
for you they have they can be they can
they are so because like you have you've
probably interacted with a pod a lot of
times without realising that you're
doing that so what can be really handy
on social media platforms but what do
they do on Wikipedia before we address
this question let's understand a little
bit more about the ecosystem of
Wikipedia websites I'm sure every person
in this room knows the English Wikipedia
very well it's the biggest online
encyclopedia with over 5.8 million
articles what you may not know is the
Wikimedia Foundation which hosts
Wikipedia also hosts a bunch of other
websites here's a few Wiktionary is the
free and open dictionary wiki voyages
the travel guide anybody can edit
Wikimedia Commons is the only repository
of free use images music videos and more
wiki source is the free library that
houses bugs essays historical documents
and wiki data is the
Oh of all knowledge in the world another
thing you might not know is that all of
these wiki's are projects are available
in multiple languages we support more
than 300 languages and 9 20 websites
across all of these projects all the
language translations are not just
content translations they are in fact
separate websites
let's also now take a quick look at the
anatomy of a wiki page here's anybody
can anybody can edit Wikipedia as you
probably know Wikimedia Foundation does
not play a role in the content on the
wiki it's maintained and added by own
wiki community you can hit edit on any
wiki page and start editing it and save
it instantly also all pages are
accompanied by a talk page where you can
go and discuss and debate the content on
a wiki page also perhaps most
importantly all wiki pages have a view
history option where you can go to see
every single meet it made to a Wikipedia
article over time you can also see every
version of the page at any given time so
content that lives on wiki's are is
governed by own wiki communities as I
mentioned and these communities are
maintained these projects have come up
with policies and guidelines that
dictate what content is allowed on the
wiki every way every community functions
like a democracy with a constitution
that that is made of policies and
guidelines that editors have come up
with for instance this is the notability
guideline on english wikipedia that
describes what content is considered
notable enough to deserve an article on
the website here's the neutrality
guideline which explains that articles
on Wikipedia must have a neutral point
of view and not be biased and this is a
verifiability guideline that states all
the content in an article must be
verifiable from external sources this
manifests itself in the form of a list
of references on every wiki page also
all of these are available on all of our
projects here is Arabic Italian Russian
all communities have their own
guidelines that they have come up with
over the years with the foundation of
policies and guidelines in place
at add content and often band together
to form groups focus groups which they
used to work on our topic areas of their
interests like and these are called wiki
projects so here's wiki project
geography that focuses entirely and
articles of geography geography wiki
project football and there's wiki
projects for almost all cities and this
one's for London there's over a thousand
such user groups of Biggie projects on
English Wikipedia alone and if you're
interested you can try and find one so
now that we have a primer on Wikipedia
let's come to the meat of the talk
what's the bottom Wikipedia what's on
Wikipedia come in many shapes and sizes
perhaps the broadest classification we
can make is authorized versus
unauthorised spots authorized bots are
ones that are that have an approval by
the community they own an account they
have an own part owner they can be
tracked and blocked if necessary if they
go rogue
unauthorized bots on the other hand are
mostly used for vandalism purposes they
often do not use an account it's hard to
track them and block them because they
originate from a variety of IP addresses
for the remainder of this talk every
time I mention a bot I am talking about
an authorized spot on the wiki
let's take a quick look at what activity
across all of our projects so bot
activity varies greatly with the project
in question across all of our Wikimedia
projects thoughts make typically the
same number of edits as human users do
it's about 17 million edits a month on
average on English Wikipedia that number
is far less they make about a quarter of
all edits that human users to about 750
thousand per month on wiki data which is
the fact repository what's make a lot
more edits about 6 to 8 million a month
8 to 10 million a month compared to
human users but so what's due a
surprising number of behind the scene
tasks on Wikipedia which you probably
never seen are encountered so let's take
a look at some of the tasks the
spots typically perform on the wikis
I've probably classified these
activities into six buckets there's
there's more specialized tasks that bots
do based on the project here's here's a
few let's go through each of these in
turn
article maintenance so these are BOTS
that do maintenance work on articles
that are meant for the end readers of
the Wikipedia these bods often go
through the highest level of scrutiny
because they work on reader facing
content I'm sure you've all seen a
references section on a Wikipedia
article it can be tremendously long all
content on an article must be backed up
by external references Colbert bod is
designed to come through English
Wikipedia as reference links
periodically and convert external HTTP
links to HTTPS links for websites that
allow it this is a pretty basic but very
important task another example of a bot
that maintains our reference links is
the Internet Archive bot it was
maintained it was designed by a
volunteer under the guidance of
Wikimedia Foundation and the Internet
Archive it periodically checks for dead
links in the reference sections of
articles and replaces them about by the
internet archive version of the page if
available another example of a bot that
maintains our articles is the common
stealing coupon when images that are
added to Wikipedia get deleted because
of copyright violation or because
they're obviously selfies they leave
behind dead links to the image the red
140px you see in that image is a dead
link the commons d linker bought cleans
up articles after image deletion and
removes links to the deleted images
what's also play a critical role in
helping new editors on Wikipedia
Wikipedia can be a scary place for new
editors to join and boss try and make
this easier host bot is an example that
friends of that sends a friendly message
to encourage newly registered users to
join in the tea house project on wiki
the tea house is a newcomer friendly
space that people can go to to ask
questions and get in
walled-in in editing activities on
Wikipedia another example is the just
part this is a smart bot that generates
a suggestion list of articles for you
based on the articles you have read or
edited based on your hedging history it
also suggests areas those articles need
help with so you can help them
what's also helped facilitate
discussions this is this pretty
important because wiki's weren't
designed with discussions as a use case
in mind this is a typical discussion
page for an article on Wikipedia as you
can see it looks nothing like
discussions to on reddit or Stack
Overflow or hacker news or any comments
section ever
that's because discussions on wiki to
happen on plain old wiki pages that you
can edit to add your comment so you can
anybody can create a new section add a
comment and then you sign your comment
with adding by adding for Tilda signs
it's quite cumbersome and often you've
run into edit conflicts with multiple
people editing the same page so as I
mentioned that you can add for tilde
signs to add your signature and that
those four till designs expand to your
user name your talk linked to your talk
page and then the timestamp and while
this is super obvious to people who have
been editing these pages over the years
it's not really that obvious to new
users this is a task that sighing pod
does for users who forget to sign their
comments and this might seem like a very
simple and harmless bot but it actually
got quite a bit of a push back when it
was first deployed on English Wikipedia
there's a whole research paper dedicated
to studying how this race simple bot
caused a mind shift mindset shift on on
Wikipedia and the early days
another bot that maintains our
discussion pages is archiver bot when
discussion pages get too long buy a lot
of content archive about archives older
discussions to archives this is again a
very simple task but very important a
lot of bots also help with facilitating
site governance
they include these include meant a lot
of clerical tasks like adding
categories flagging problematic edits
supporting on wiki voting generating
custom feeds and a lot more Delta quad
board is one example it reports newly
registered users whose username
suspicious like they claim to be
official or they claim to belong to a
company
another example is re bod which adds
stub tags to very short articles
encouraging people to add more content
you might recognize the English version
of this also I should mention that
please don't expand this list by
committing massacres combat copyright
violations this is something that bots
don't do it very often lately it's a
critical function that they used to
perform in the past is now more or less
been replaced by an external tool Korn
search pod is an example of a pod that
performed this task it was extensively
used on English Wikipedia to help
English patrollers detect copyright
violations and last but not the least
combating vandalism is in arguably one
of the most critical functions at BOTS
perform on the wikis I'm sure you've all
seen and chuckled at instances of
vandalism on Wikipedia maybe you even
vandalized it with one example vandalism
when Wikipedia
so this is like pretty harmless right
you know you vandalize did you take a
screenshot what nobody is harmed but it
is a lot of nuisance to editors who
clean up after the Randell right and you
can vandalism can range from very
amateurish additions to outright
vandalism like page blocking blanking or
spam articles or creating articles by
yourself about about yourself so before
we look into how vandalism is battled on
the wikis today let's take a quick peek
into the history of bots on Wikipedia
mandal ism has played a very important
role in shaping how bots work on the
Wikipedia today and that's made it
resilient against trolls on the Internet
these days back in 2006 the first known
mass vandalism attack happened on
English Wikipedia somebody began
blanking pages and replacing them with
an image of a squid supposedly after the
Squidward Tentacles character from
Sponge Bob Squarepants
using multiple user accounts or proxies
then probably a bot the Squidward vandal
was one of the worst nightmare of all
the comedians at the time the tag went
on for months with hundreds of thousands
of articles vandalized it took a lot of
manual effort on editors for the wrong
editors to track down these vandalism
edits and fix them in the face of this
for Wikipedians came up with the
anti-vandal bot it was a first attempt
at automated vandalism protection on
Wikipedia it used a very simple set of
rules to admire too recent edits and
based on those rules it reverted and
it's which filled those rules for
borderline cases it would flag the edits
to be looked over by human editors
although it's quite crude by today's
standards anti-vandal bought nonetheless
saved the editors a lot of time and
effort and according to several
researchers it saved the website from
its doom anti-vandal board has since
been replaced by several more
intelligent fight vandals and fighting
bots
the newest iteration of this is the clue
pod next generation whoever next
generation makes use of artificial
intelligence to detect
lism edits and does a pretty good job of
it it uses the neural network to detect
patterns in edits and because wiki's
preserve all edits I'll edit history for
all articles a lot of data was available
from past instances of vandalism to
train the bots the verge did an article
on club on next-generation
titled this Machine Kills trolled so you
know it's serious business let's take a
look at a few of club our next
generations edits so this is a diff
viewer the text highlighted and read was
removed by the BOD in this case somebody
vandalized a page to request the page be
protected against vandalism and this
one's my favorite because it's not
really easy to tell that that's
vandalism but it's it was smart boy it
was smart enough to catch this it also
has a web interface where people can
report false positives and the
programmers can look over them and tweak
the bots to be better it's quite
sophisticated and as with most bots on
Wikipedia the code is available on
github and anybody can use it and fork
it Club RNG is awesome
but it has one downside it only works on
English and it doesn't protect the other
Wikipedia's out there so you might be
wondering what goes into writing these
awesome BOTS it's not that complicated
really idea there's there's a lot of
community pages on Wikipedia's where you
can go and where you can go and request
a bot that you like so editors often
request BOTS for simple tasks that they
do every day that's a good source for
ideas tech stack over the years multiple
bot frameworks have popped up to make it
easier to parse me devaki API responses
or do authentication these are available
in a lot of different languages although
Python and PHP are the clear favorites
development as I mentioned all of almost
all of our wikipedia bots are publicly
available on github and open source so
that's a valuable resource
there's also a lot of frameworks
available there's a lot of documentation
although it's hard to find yeah and then
hosting bots can be hosted anywhere
Wikimedia Foundation offers a cloud
hosting platform where most bots are
hosted that run on the wikis testing
bots can be tested on a lab testing wiki
that we have available there's beta
cluster wikis which can be used for
these purposes community approval this
is probably the biggest and most
important all bots that run on a wiki
must become approved by the key
community so different wiki's have
different ways to do this I'll touch
upon this more in a second and
deployment maintenance once approved by
the community the bots can be deployed
and run on the wiki so as I showed you a
few policies earlier there's also a
policy about bots on wiki's this is the
English Wikipedia policy and bots the
board policy governs what bots are
allowed to do one week in what they're
not there is also a bot approvals group
which is a group of users who oversee
the activities and BOTS and taken upon
themselves to monitor these what edits
so yeah we've seen how BOTS can help
Wikipedia and sister websites they
perform a lot critical functions they
defend the website they help readers get
more out of it they help the editors
were more effective it's awesome
but is it always that awesome not always
sometimes very well-intentioned but can
we also be trouble I'll be taking you
through two examples of cases where bots
did stuff that was you know unwanted or
not required here's this is more of a
fact than anything bots are dumped and
they can end up doing silly things like
getting into fights with our other BOTS
this has happened a few times in
wikipedia history where bots keep
reverting each other's edits and then
the cycle goes on so bots are not all
that different from us right this was
researched upon and presented in a paper
published last year the paper caught the
eye of
more than a few media outlets and which
took the title quite literally
the TLDR of the paper was that they
performed a study over ten years to see
how many times but edit other reward
other bots and the number went as high
as about thirty four thousand on English
Wikipedia in 2009 well let that may seem
like a high number it's actually quite
tiny compared to the total number of
edits on the website every month
nonetheless it is a case of BOTS
behaving in an unexpected and unwanted
manner let's take a look at a bigger
example now well as I mentioned earlier
English Wikipedia is the biggest online
encyclopedia of all all the Hippias
right it's about 5.8 million articles
but kidding yes which is the second
biggest Wikipedia nope it's a trick
question of course No
so it's a language that you have
probably never heard of it's the Cebuano
Wikipedia also commonly known as beside
is the language spoken by about 21
million people in the Philippines it's
not even the biggest language spoken in
the Philippines and as you can tell
where this is going right if you look at
the other numbers there's already
something suspicious there is about 1200
admins in English and five on cebuano
124 thousand users active users in
English and 167 on soprano in fact even
the third biggest language they're
swedish is also a bot written language
like Cebuano so what what's the bot
causing this it's called lsj bot
this is the user page at that pod which
doesn't have all that content but
funnily enough there is the Wikipedia
page for that bot that has a lot more
content about it Elizabeth was written
by Sivir kiyaah Hansen a Swedish long
term editor back in the day and his idea
was to generate articles automated
automatically generate translated
articles based on facts published by
government agencies or data sources
online his idea was that
it's better to have some content about
something rather than having no content
about it and that has led to a case like
this on sabana Wikipedia these might
seem like really random strings of
numbers but these are articles about
actual water Springs in the United
States here's one and here's the English
translated version it contains very
basic factual data about the spring
level height Direction habitation in the
area terrain etc
you've probably never heard of the
spring and there's a good reason for
that there's I in fact only two other
Google search heads for the spring one
of them as you guessed it is the source
of this data the national water quality
monitoring council they did not even
consider having an acronym friendly name
and the second website NES is there was
the second google search for it paid for
this it's Google Maps no offense to the
spring but it really is a notable enough
to be on Wikipedia I have Google more
google searches than that so while this
data might be useful to architects or
water companies or conference speakers
it isn't really notable enough to merit
inclusion and Wikipedia and that's why
English Wikipedia has a strict policy
against this but on cebuano wikipedia at
the time the community was convinced
that having more articles on the wiki is
a good thing so as a result 99% of that
wikipedia is written by the bots so
according to a lot of researchers that
came up after that after the fact it it
was it's proven that there are this has
caused several problems on the wiki the
local language content was almost
completely drowned out with everything
you search for it turns up stabbed
article created by a bot maintenance is
a huge task
so editors who should be writing more
content are now fighting a vandal than
maintaining this content and then it
sparked the numbers war among local
Wikipedia's where people thought that
having
more and more articles on the wiki is a
good thing and then a few other
Philippine wiki's also opted in for the
pod and got a lot of these Springs on
their wiki too but I don't want to put I
want don't want to put you off of
writing a pod with this because BOTS can
can be have can be super awesome but
there can also be consequences like
these but nonetheless you should try and
write a bot what's a very important for
Wikipedia websites to help a tribe by
performing article maintenance edits
helping editors fighting of vandalism
defending the website and they are also
a great way to contribute towards the
sum of all human knowledge Wikipedia is
also a very friendly place when you
developers to write BOTS because there's
nobody to look at your code it's yours
and you can write the way you want
there's also a lot of resources to look
at there's open source bots to learn
from there's frameworks to use and last
but not least it can be a very rewarding
experience to create something simple
that helps hundreds of people perform
tasks they want more efficiently
and that's it
thank you so much
[Applause]